aí é que assistir o canal do bom
conselho galera não estamos aqui pra ver
um momento maravilhoso que é o que a lua
sangre em karama chove como ela tava
feito fofoca a droga só posta não sei
minha gente eu fiquei sabendo que a
sobrinha ficava m hoje não todo mundo
vou vê-lo o velo não me move é também eu
tenho que ver a luz ambiente senão como
é que eu vou baixar não fez não vai
mudar a vida ninguém
vamos ver vou mostrar pra vocês a
verdadeira luta sangrenta macho a lua
vai ficar vermelho uma vez e olha a
desgraça de nuvem que tenha esse céu
mais calma porque ela só vai estar
totalmente vermelha 4 e 20 por que será
que ela vai estava em 64 e 2010 já estou
muito feliz aonde vai mudar muito a
minha vida porque a lua menstrual ou
inclusive estava preocupado porque mês
passado eu não sei com a lua na época
aconteceu e eu estou preocupado disse no
começo eu acho que eu posso ser o pai
tava que a china sabe que eu sei que
esse momento nesse mesmo ano neste mesmo
o twitter muito tinha um monte de gente
vai ficar gata já no metrô lá então fico
mais confortável que eu sei que não sou
o único que besse o que está fazendo
isso aí
o eclipse bonitos aluno ingresse cara
mas como está mas a luz ambiente achim k
eu tô porte eita como tá linda essa lua
em olha só que bonito olha tá ficando
sem luz ali eu acho que vou conseguir ir
no meu deus me útil isto tudo é preciso
ver se a lua do ruído ela militar e eu
tentei quinta mas já começa a equipe se
machucou meu deus mostra o melhor do
jogo para ver isso tudo aqui ao vivo
qual vive aqui na minha frente tipo até
agora já faz tempo e nada dessa não
aparecer e estou preocupado mas essa no
méxico a equipe vai ser meio que não
militar por filhos da lua do ano homem
o aluno não não gostou não quero ficar
gostosa porque vai dar trabalho no fio
do cabelo ruim muito frio e fome come
with love e ronaldo no ronaldo não na do
meu terminal do mundo foi mulher pode
ser pode ser lua bonita é bonita no
entanto ainda não meu deus meu deus não
vai morar com essa desgraça na chegada
enquanto o seu nono ministro fazer uma
propaganda de sala de estar pra vocês
olá você já conhece as nossas
instalações
nós temos as melhores salas para você e
para sua família
o melhor madeira trazida diretamente de
nárnia para que você se sinta melhor com
seus amigos sala de estar do inter som
venha
tudo em ter na minha vida eu entendo
sentido eu entendo entendo tudo assim em
plena forma de barco ou doeu em do
teorema de pitágoras eu entenda o valor
de chito a única coisa que eu não
entendo o que desgraça essa nuvem está
fazendo aqui na frente da women's do ano
eu deus alguém me dá uma explicação ao
dn não há explicação para isso a lutar e
é exatamente aí mas eu não posso vela
por causa dessa nuvem desgraçada em
nuvem nos satanás arrependido
elas vão sair dali ameaça embora e volta
só queria ver são uma vermelha mas é só
isso que eu queria todo mundo falando
disso o facebook eo twitter imagens só
queria ver isso doeu só queria ver isso
doido doido muda muita coisa que eu
quero ver tudo é essa lua vermelha só
isso que eu vou fazer mas não à solta a
voz só para a água sai opera mesmo que
ainda falta 20 minutos ou 20 minutos
para ver essa desgraça
portanto eu sozinho já acham que o
satanás então o diretor que a hora do
toque do olho do 880 feição do outro daí
começa a chuva e do outro a tomar no meu
co a nuvital sair na qual os apanhar da
lua não são de diabo porque ela foi
parar - cabeça no outro cara não viam o
vermelho no brasil bicho quero ver na
copa é você ver que ela não vendo
vermelha e o povo da manhã
galera eu estava assistindo aqui pelo
computador a transmissão da nasa mostra
nessa lua fica vermelha e do nada do
nada essa luta ficou branca de não dar
aqui daqui onde o autor de fortaleza não
consigo ver a nasa não tem mostrar esse
tempo servido a culpa disso tudo eu sei
o que significa
sabe o que significa que o michael
jackson está vivo e anotam embora eu não
tô vendo bem do jeito que o brasil tá
roubar a lua começou a chuva e agora
obrigado tempo obrigado universo para
bem agora só porque a chuva no nordeste
uma em jequié croma que onde tem que
admitir a aí o papiamento todinha
acordado que o carregue a minha câmera
todinho seu futuro agora só te faça uma
pergunta pra quem ta nea do verde e meus
filhos eu mesmo posso fazer isso e
mostrar aqui pela internet essa aqui é a
lua vermelha pra vocês nossa que benê
mas sim legal em nossa que beleza que
lindo atacou a natureza do nosso dessa
luta vermelha aonde depois a galera se
cover de hoje minha tentativa de gelo
fim em si um diálogo a lei não podia
roubar um então clique no gosto nesse
vídeo pode falar que vai ser decidido
vai ficar muito 88 ainda falar em festa
no hotel com a teles sangrar e deixando
a vermelha anderson que gostei de tudo
gostei que você dá até me ajudando
demais eu quero que você comente aqui
embaixo você conseguiu ver a desgraça de
flor vermelha na sociedade que sim como
é que foi se não viu posso recepção como
tem que ser a primeira vez que você está
vendo aqui no meu canal clique em
inscrever-se toda vez que chove de novo
e saber na e do euro